so this is his hero with the incredibly
still incredibly odd voice of Lou
Ferrigno doesn't his voice stick out
like a sore thumb on here before I
realized it was Lou Ferrigno I was just
wondering what was wrong with the voice
and it sounds rude and it sounds like
evil and whatnot but it's one of those
looks like wow they picked a really odd
voice for the theater but it for me or
worse cuz it's adventure time and
because things are so strange as like
you can have him talking that strange
voice you know just fine I think we see
him do like cameos and other stuff he's
like supposed to be acting normal is
that yeah that doesn't work so so it's
like when he does something like this
it's like it I think it works pretty
well yeah so he plays a character called
Billy really who has six fingers I think
yes and a diamond for a nose yeah that
and and he says he's done with
adventuring through like violence if
they wants to do nonviolent ways and
Finn and Jake clearly aren't that good
at it I don't even know if he's that
good at it because what's he do he's
just stuck in that cave with a bunch of
stuff like he's not going out and doing
like they come back you still there he's
like sitting on top of a broken TV a B
units it doesn't look like he's doing
that much good so nevertheless they go
they try to do like good stuff they try
to a community service kind of thing or
what they think is community service but
they kind of make things worse possibly
because they still work in violence
somehow even if it is like defense but
like wasn't magic nails that they keep
using and it keeps giving people like
weapons and stuff you know turning that
into weapons and which makes for some
good comedy the the stuff with the
cobbler yeah especially that poor
friggin cobbler oh I think I have some
favorites will they they have a shoe for
this woman going to a funeral
especially fancy - yeah and yeah puts it
on and has all these little weapons on
it also has a little lasso
and at lassos the guide the cobbler it
just pulls him and just like face out
just drags him up to her and he just
stays face down for like 20 seconds and
uh anything a guy can be where someone's
hurt and they're like face down and
something is usually really funny it
just played for comedy if it's like real
and sad that's really really hilarious
oh yeah that's true too
but yeah so it's I liked outright try
think of any other like any other major
things and I love sort of that weird I
mean it's all weird but like how it cuts
halfway into the music lazy get out of
here in the running away that just cuts
to him like nodding watching them go
away then like cuts in the middle of
that it's like just I'm still so amazed
at how unexpected and random they can
make this stuff and still have it be
funny because I mean that that is so
tricky to do I guess I remember while
watching Ren's did be growing up like at
some point it's like okay I'm sorry
I know they change people but at the
same time that's like okay I'm sort of
getting sick of answers getting a
formula or my Python's Flying Circus
like they started yeah won't be a
formula and I love my plate those Flying
Circus but after a while you're like
okay they're gonna go this direction or
that direction or a third Rock do the
same thing here it's like I really I you
I couldn't predict the jokes if you pay
me like a million dollars like I could
not predict what joke was coming next
and that is so refreshing and that is so
nice so yeah okay can't think it too
much I'll smile at you um I really like
the fact that when they find Billy they
flip out and like they're the ultimate
like fanboys and everything and then
what happened to that dog by the way the
skin of the dog I just realized that
they show those galton Jake's I'm gonna
pass out it's like that was great what
happened to that dog
yeah um yet yes yes no prior reveals him
maybe but no I love the fact that he's
sitting there and he's just like you
know violence is pointless violence is
stupid you know you should you should
never do violence go help people in
other ways and you're right he just sits
there but well at the end when you see
he has no heart
it's kind of like I think I took it more
like you just completely gave up on
doing anything yeah it seems more like
you just got tired mmm are you or maybe
that the whole nonviolent thing is just
an excuse for him to sit around and not
do anything
that's very trying in a non-violent way
like trying to make it sound more
oppressive there really is to help him
grow his heart back and he calls forth
his sword what to me keeps sounding like
he says no tongue what does he
everything I don't know but every time I
hear it it says no tongue and also the
sword comes to him and I'm like could be
Newton Newton that's possible but you
know yeah I'm always because I think
there's so many I might be out of them
like one a few people or whatever but
like I want a few people that doesn't
always see like violence as necessarily
a bad thing especially in defense yeah
you know but I'm definitely not II hey
punch him first ask questions later it's
like no I'm like there's gonna be times
you're gonna need to defend yourself
it's gonna be free we're gonna use
violence and it's just it's just trying
to even it out trying to know when and
why and all that stuff so I always find
it interesting when I show especially a
kids show cuz
kids don't need to be told hey hit more
things yeah you know I mean because like
they got that down pretty good but at
the same time it's kind of nice to see
something that's not totally like every
single bit of violence is bad like
they're there there are times to fight
there are times yeah right back and yeah
I mean here it's like here's this giant
evil monster coming that that we're
gonna run into many giant evil monsters
but we're gonna run into yet people or
whatever they're probably gonna try and
hurt us at st. and you got defend
yourself so I do sort of like that they
do show you know if you can find that
route great and finish it do try to find
solutions that aren't always violent em
yeah they like adventure but I don't
think they're like blood-hungry
necessarily sober Jake maybe yeah most
likely
again thank god he has been but yeah so
I think that I think than just saying
like okay no violence at all never ever
again and they Circe alone only
sometimes we do sort of need you know to
fight
or use for us when our people are using
for it you know but always as like a
last resort sort of thing well if you
know they don't have besides the last
resort that much but still well if you
look at the like the last episode the
what did you do remember he's like I
just can't beat on the Ice King
yeah to make these sounds I that's
against what I do so he has the clear
clip clear-cut boundaries of when to use
violence and when not he's not just
gonna wail on someone just a wail on him
but when he sees this big monster
picking on the little old lady again
finalist towards old people yeah even
here there's like it old never trust old
people it's like that this show has the
weirdest attitude towards old people
yeah I don't know what its deal is ah
you don't know yeah but but but it hits
you right in the gut there's your damn
Segway yeah you do
yes I I wasn't done yet though it's
gonna talk a little bit more of a sort
of a premium in you know a premature
segue but with that said before I so
we're really interrupted by your
premature segue tell me when you're done
then I will do it again you already did
it once it's grinding me yeah you're
really better than I am okay then yours
was fine
are they yes thank you yeah it's it's
okay I I I got a bit aggressive I maybe
had a little bubble gum in me and I do
apologize I forgot what I was gonna talk
about it matters not all that matters is
our friendship
I agree friend can we go to adventure
things let's go
don't touch me there